TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME, YAHOO
ANSWERS.
YAHOO ANSWERS.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
WELL... WOW, THIS IS, UH...
SORT OF WEIRD AND
TELEPORTATION-AL.
I SEE THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE
JOINED BY STAR OF THE NEW SHOW
BACKSTROM, PREMIERING JANUARY 22
ON FOX, RAINN WILSON IS HERE?
BR-BROUGHT HIS OWN PODIUM?
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
(HONKING)
>> HARDWICK: I SEE THAT... I SEE
THAT YOU BROUGHT YOUR OWN
PODIUM, TOO?
>> YES, I DID.
HANDCRAFTED IN MY GARAGE.
>> HARDWICK: THAT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> WELL, THE GAME IS CALLED
YA-HOO ANSWERS, CHRIS, AND...
>> HARDWICK: YAHOO, GRANDPA.
THANK YOU.
>> YA-HOO?
>> HARDWICK: WHAT ON EARTH ARE
YOU DOING HERE @MIDNIGHT?
>> OKAY, I WROTE THIS LINE.
"WELL, THE GAME IS CALLED YAHOO
ANSWERS, AND I PLAY A DETECTIVE
ON MY NEW TV SHOW WHO HAS ALL
THE ANSWERS.
HASHTAG..."
(HONKING)
SO THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
SHAMELESS PLUG.
>> HARDWICK: I GOT TO BE HONEST,
THAT'S-THAT'S PRETTY BAD
WRITING.
>> THAT'S TERRIBLE.
>> HARDWICK: THIS IS... BUT...
I MEAN, I'LL TELL YOU THIS
THOUGH, RAINN, I ADORE YOU AND
WE'VE BEEN FRIENDS A LONG TIME
AND THIS IS COMPLETELY
UNPRECEDENTED IN @MIDNIGHT
HISTORY, BUT WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW A FOURTH CONTESTANT HERE.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
>> MAKE IT RAINN.
>> HARDWICK: HERE'S HOW THIS
WORKS: I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A
REAL QUESTION POSED BY A REAL
DUMMY ON YAHOO ANSWERS, AND YOU
HAVE TO BUZZ IN WITH YOUR FUNNY
ANSWERS.
UH, PUT YOUR ANSWERS WHERE YOUR
MOUTH IS.
60 SECONDS STARTING NOW.
WHAT IS THE SADDEST PLACE ON
EARTH?
WHITNEY.
(HONKING)
>> UH, INSIDE THAT HORN.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
THAT'S VERY... A VERY SAD PLACE.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE, NEXT
QUESTION, IS RAINN WILSON
(DWIGHT FROM THE OFFICE) DEAD?
JEFF.
>> RAINN IS STILL ALIVE, BUT
SEVERAL WOMEN HE'S BEEN DATING
HAVE DISAPPEARED.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
RAINN WILSON.
>> WELL, HE'S DOING A SHOW ON
FOX, SO YES.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
UH... NEXT QUESTION.
WHEN DOES THE ANGEL ENTER THE
WOMB?
(BELL DINGS)
LET'S START WITH JEFF ROSS.
>> AFTER SIX JACK AND COKES.
>> HARDWICK: UH, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
RAINN.
>> AFTER ANGEL-INGUS?
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
POINTS.
>> POINTS!
ANOTHER YAHOO ANSWER QUESTION.
WHAT TO DO WITH $20 WORTH OF
BACON?
(BELL DINGS)
JEFF ROSS.
>> USE IT TO GET PAULA DEEN WET.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
DAVE KOECHNER.
>> UH, IT'S AN EXCELLENT HORS
D'OEUVRE FOR, UH, CHRIS
CHRISTIE.